ブーフ org
京越もとちょっと違う動画を出します
僕が今住んでいる街は別府という旧市の東海岸に位置する自然にあふれる静かなところ
でや人口は12万にといっても同じレベルの田舎町に住んでいないと想像できないと
思うのでつい
あれスターバックスが一つしかないということも伝えておく
椎名林檎が来てくれないから小さすぎると思うときもあるがそれでも大好きな別府市で
あるそれは別府にはとても独特の特徴があるからだ
韓国と中国の視聴者たちがうんうんと頷いていたそう
温泉デップは世界最大の温泉してやり
日本の総源泉数の10分の1を占める山と海に挟まれたそんな別府は常に地面から神秘
的な湯気を大量に出していて観光客を魅了している
地元のプライドが妙に高い人がは来たくなるような町である
こんなに味のあるも違う
存在するなんて知らなかった
シアトルごめん今回僕が別府について話しているのは自分が jr になり
別府市長からお金をもらって前上がる湯気をジブリの風景に例えながら自分の浴衣姿を
アップしたいからでもなく実はその正反対である
僕はこの動画を見ている人たちに別府市町に寄付してもらいたい
説明
する今からステレオタイプを言う日本人は仕事を慎重にする人が多い
この傾向には良い面もあれば悪い女 more
毎年淘汰はさらに燃費の良いプリウスを発売するが誰も山の上に温泉遊園地を作ろうと
思う
ごめんいた別府の中の主張だ去年の11月下旬に
別府死覇装が遊べる温泉投資構想を発表した
山上温泉遊園地を描く動画を youtube に投稿しん
当動画の再生数が100万にたしたら
遊園地を実現すると宣言
た言うまでもなく話題精一杯の発表だった動画は4日間で100万に達し現在は
300万近くまで伸びている
そして市長は早速遊園地が実現するためのインフラを立て始め
先日2月10日にクラウドファンディングキャンペーンを公開した
まるで登録さが100万人
になったらエッジの動画を作るといって最近話題になっている
巨乳ユーチューバーのようだ正しいやっているの日本人の柱尿とか
しかも政治から作ると言っているのは卑猥な動画じゃなくて山の上のゆうえんちだと
しかも税金を使わずにクラウドファンディングを通してだ
あ今報告が入った
どうやら2が飛んでいるような国籍を問わず日本に住んでいる者ならこれがいかに異常
な行動であるか分かるはずだ
とてつもない勇気が必要だ村上隆の sixty nine の主人公が政治家になっ
たみたいなフィギュアを使い好きか
ポイントはフェイクニュースと侮辱が挨拶のように飛び顔現在
んこんなことを大胆にやろうとしている長野市長がとても好きで
積極的に応援したいと思うだからこの動画を作ったんだ
市長は立派なクラウドファンディングページを作り
すでにかなりの寄付を集めているが
キャンペーンには問題と思われる点が2つほどはそれは日本語のページしかないことと
最低寄付が3000円になっていることを様は一部の人にとっては応援したくても仕様
がない構成になっている理由
この問題を解決するために僕は自分ができることをやってみたいと思うついてこい
pk se た a ジェラードプロジェクターファース開けメンズ ed
newing se 生物顔なーん
エンダーウォッチ中です8 cards クイーンバーフォード別途ローズバルーン
click to support プロジェクター2グラムアクセがー
in to me as respond
sendmail again for amaba somap gobaud
メーンクロン s 4スティゲーム名あ
5ベッドページ re しゅいんぷ uruu ジョニー年フォーメーション
new パス4
これくらい this to ano せる up to b カメページェンツアー
ren this ページ22種あ日本語バック2 d with ウィング
wedding ウィッグ only be 関平ちょぎゅあ
う敬遠です後1 bd めぬまむふぁいすとぅーすりーターズにあのフォームを
pou dou dou 男優 oda カーフォーメーションページ
mu ダムだページ
ゆぎゅファイのノリとケーション3フェンスウェイターページェンド a
グラデーション10 p カーム pay to
how to 住めディングし
はいこれで皆さんを日本語のページの使い方が分かったと思う
しかし3000円の最低寄付はまだまだ多くの人にとっては高すぎると思うんで火曜日
の昼頃この動画をアップした後で僕は別府市役所に電話牛
この動画のことを説明してより安い寄付金額を追加してもらうように行ってみた
いとうしたらうまくいけば日本語できない人もカップラーメン生活を送っている人も
貢献できるようになるかと思うはいみなさんありがとうございます
冒頭で言ったようにかなり面白い発想だと思うので全力で応援したいです
中野出張こんなにぶっ飛んだ企画をやってくださってありがとうございます遊園地の
開演
大変楽しみにしています